today we will reach the unconscionable
tragic milestone of 100,000 dead
americans from coronavirus their that is
a number we may have already reached by
the time you listen to today's show or
watched today's program and that is a
number that we have reached with
widespread now allegations of data
suppression in a number of different
states which I will discuss with you on
tomorrow's program but it we've already
passed 100,000 is the point whether we
officially get there today or yesterday
or tomorrow we we actually have passed
that number
some time ago due to the believed
suppression and a mischaracterization of
some deaths and as this is going on the
president of the united states has been
tweeting allegations that a TV host
murdered someone without any evidence
and donald trump also tweeted or
retweeted a tweet calling hillary
clinton a skank but today i want to talk
about these murder smears that donald
trump has been making against MSNBC's
joe scarborough Donald Trump tweeting
quote a lot of interest in this story
about psycho Joe Scarborough so a young
marathon runner just happened to faint
in his office hit her head on his desk
and died I would think that there is a
lot more to this story than that
an affair what about the so-called
investigator Reid story
Trump also tweeted a blow to her head
body found under his desk
left Congress suddenly big topic of
discussion in Florida and he's a nut job
with bad ratings
keep digging use forensic geniuses so
what this all relates to is a Joe
Scarborough staffer that died in 2001
was a 28 year old woman lori class Udhas
and conspiracy theories started about
her death pretty quickly down in Florida
and this is 19 years ago Trump is now
reviving this and giving it oxygen Media
Mia merely because he is in a media
battle with Joe Scarborough because he
doesn't like joe scarborough's coverage
of donald trump on MSNBC that's all that
this is
but the president is accusing a media
host he does not like of murder even
many Republicans are disgusted by this
Illinois Republican Rep Adam Kinzinger
tweeted quote completely unfounded
conspiracy just stop stop spreading it
stop creating paranoia it will destroy
us Fox News bomb-thrower Brit Hume even
tweeting quote 30,000 retweets for this
discredited tale based on a three year
old post from some wingding web site
this is why even his critics should want
Trump to play a lot of golf because when
he does he's not tweeting crap like this
so the analysis here is 90% obvious and
I want to focus on the 10% that maybe is
less obvious of course in that 90% yes
this is not normal
yes the world is laughing and crying and
pitying us yes
Trump accusing people of murder on
Twitter is an absolute and total horror
as 100,000 people have died of
coronavirus in the United States with as
many as 2/3 of those deaths preventable
with just a couple week earlier call for
national stay at home orders the only
remaining question is why Trump is still
allowed on Twitter and I got a lot of
emails over the weekend from from you
guys saying David you know Trump is he's
specifically targeting someone with
false allegations with a conspiracy
theory that person Joe Scarborough is
being bullied now Joe Scarborough is
getting death threats and how is this
how is Twitter allowing this what you
have to understand is Twitter has very
specific rules for what you can and
can't say but they have different rules
for famous people in politicians and
Twitter put out rules last year I
believe it was which I'm characterizing
it in the way I see it you can read the
full text of it if you want if a world
leader or a politician tweets something
that would normally violate their policy
like for example in this case Trump is
targeting an individual for mass
bullying like Trump did by saying Joe
Scarborough might have murdered someone
if it's Trump if they leave it up
because the mere fact that it's Trump
who said it makes it newsworthy in a way
where it's newsworthiness and the fact
that it will be reported on necessitates
leaving it up so that it can be properly
reported on is is sort of the gist to it
and I understand that but Twitter can
also say make the news elsewhere right
it's not what we want our community to
be used for making news about imagine
being the family of twenty then twenty
eight-year-old Laurie class Udhas you've
been trying to recover from an
inconceivably traumatic event that took
place 19 years ago where your 28 year
old family member died and in comes the
President of the United States
retweeting a three-year-old conspiracy
article from a nonsense website all
because he doesn't like joe
scarborough's coverage of him this is an
era listen the Trump era is going to be
an era where number one we should never
forgive the Trump administration nor the
people who voted to put him in power but
as a country hopefully at some point we
fix this atrocity hopefully it's in five
months it might not be until four years
and five months which would be tragic I
hope eventually the world is able to
forget the United States as a country
I'm not saying forgive the Trump voters
and I'm certainly not saying forgive
Trump in his administration but I hope I
hope that at some point the world will
forgive us as a country for this
absolute aberration that hopefully will
only last for years but may last eight
years if we don't take care of business
on November third one of our sponsors is
privacy calm they're giving you $5.00
when you sign up for their completely
free service at privacy calm slash
Pakman I've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before it's a lifesaver
and here's how it works takes just a
couple of minutes to set up anytime you
buy something online or on the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app and
the browser plugin let you give each
company a randomized virtual credit card
number that you create out of thin air
it'll even autofill the card number with
one click and the payment is taken out
of your checking account without the
merchant ever knowing your real
information so this allows you to keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create up to 12 of these virtual credit
cards a month you can set spending
limits you can freeze them you can
delete them anytime you want so when you
do this it means you're not going to be
charged when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number right after using it which for
instance I love using free trials
because I know I won't be charged when
the trial is over if I use a virtual
credit card number you're keeping your
identity private by not telling
companies who you are you're keeping
your bank or credit card info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free there's no catch
whatsoever but if you want privacy also
offers a $10 a month plan that gives you
one percent cashback and lets you create
36 credit cards a month and a $25 a
month plan tailored more for small
businesses where you can create 60 card
numbers a month and much more but
definitely go ahead and at least get
started with a free plan you'll protect
your financial info companies can't
charge you unexpectedly and like I said
you'll get $5 to spend when you sign up
at privacy calm / Pakman